hey guys and welcome back to steampunks
GameSpot's pc focus show where we talk
about everything PC it's fairly
straightforward this week we're talking
about shutter with the Tomb Raider which
is out this week broadly the Tomb Raider
series and what platform you should play
the game on but we also want to talk
about what platform you should play any
other game obviously like there are
heaps of third-party titles that come
out on all systems these days like a lot
of consoles and I kind of like
comparable to pcs like sort of mid mid
to high range pcs and so if you own
multiple consoles and you're in a PC you
might have the same dilemma that you
know I always have it's like what
console what platform should I play this
game on yeah I just really enjoyed the
precision I can get with the keyboard
and mouse whether it's shooting whether
it's action I like being able to know
exactly what I'm doing and be able to
get there quickly and I feel like I
don't have that control with the
controller first-person games I will
always use mouse and keyboard just
because so things like doom and you know
just on it a lot of Bethesda titles and
shooters and overwatch especially but if
it's a third person game I will
absolutely use a controller even if I'm
playing on PC because I just feel like
the way you can move the cameras more
smoothly on a third person game sort of
suits controller better you shouldn't be
ashamed of not using a mass of people at
on PC because obviously steam especially
integrates the Xbox one and PlayStation
4 controllers perfectly so you don't
even need to worry about compatibility
you can even make them wireless
it's tough to need an adapter that
certainly has both a built-in bluetooth
you can connect with your PC and so that
registering mean issue unless you don't
already have a console laying around
what I do like with controllers is
usually the mapping is really great yeah
that was the case for a game like Alice
madness Returns when you have so many
weapons it's really nice when the
developers gone to the effort to map the
multi buttons it can get really
difficult hell-blade is a great example
of a game that should not be played with
a mouse and cable it is so hard to hit
all like the different bits and pieces
hit your dodges make sure you're pairing
and blocking there are a lot of
different case and just like I ended up
with like a claw on my keyboard
desperately trying to hit all the
what I ran up against which is the third
person game is I really wanted to play
the division on Pacey but all my friends
are playing on ps4 so that's where I
ended up that ended up being to
advantage because there's a lot of hack
is the vision had heaps of hack is on PC
so you know probably your aim didn't
really matter at the immunity I think as
well there were sensible reasons for
picking things up on Pacey especially if
you already have one is it's always
gonna look better especially when you
can play with mouse keyboard control of
whatever suits you to have the best
fidelity version of the game has to be
the biggest drawer I go back to to
minute for a little bit like I remember
with the original team in our review I
kind of like um Denard over which
platform to use because at that time to
my PC was kind of on par with like
Playstation and the Xbox but then I
realized like you know certain game
engines like the ones Square Enix users
always have like Nvidia style you know
extra bonus like you happy just like
tres effects in here and all that kind
of stuff so I was like yes that's what I
want I'm gonna play it on PC and so
that's what I did but now I'm kind of
thinking that with the Xbox one X and
the PlayStation 4 Pro and I have like
both of those and I've also got like a
PC with a 1070 unit it's pretty much you
know apples for apples yeah so then it
comes down to a do I want to play this
game on my couch or do I want to sit you
know upright like my desk in play with
the controller and so that's it's there
it's the whole experience that you need
to kind of consider when it comes to
games like as you say like multi players
or shared experiences especially games
where you're playing with other people
for example unravel to is a game I've
been planning to get into and I picked
that up on ps4 and not on PC because I
can't imagine me in my housemate
gathered around no you're gonna play
couch co-op welcome local multiplayer on
me exactly and yet they are available
there and then you know I don't care
about Xbox achievements or like on steam
achievements but I really care about
PlayStation trophies for some reason
just because I that's my biggest
collection I kind of just want to keep
feeding it yeah and then it then comes
the switch you know there's obviously a
ton of really great indie games and I
love indie games and the thing about
indie games is they often release on PC
steam first right so if you want to get
get on the cutting edge of like what's
really hot dead cells early access
Celeste you know I'll use controllers
and that's fine
but you know if I know they're gonna
come to switch like do I spend 15 to 20
bucks buying a copy on PC or just wait
to spend my money on the switch version
and it's like do I want to play now what
can I can I hold off so maybe the best
way of wrapping this one up after going
through all these games is just which
platforms we're gonna get showed of the
Tomb Raider on I already made my really
obvious I really think that's like the
rest of the series on PC and I love it
that way yeah well I think I'm gonna
play mine on peaceful for some dumb
reasons really
I like the controller obviously and I
this is definitely a game that I want to
play on the couch yeah and you know i've
i've got i've also been like a huge
streak this year of like platinum in
games like i'm fighting more games with
you now back to the church and so i just
like you know what it looks fine you
know like screw the xbox partnership i'm
just gonna get it on playstation you
like get my trophies and that's really
stupid but these are the little kind of
things that yeah you use to make it as
it is do you let us know down in that
comment box what you guys are reckon
you'll be playing multi-platform games
on this year and thank you for your
comments about last week's video on
whether you should preorder games now
obviously a lot of you just said flat
out you know you just don't pre-order
games but a lot of people actually have
admitted to like making the dumb mistake
of pre-ordering and getting better in
games but the Roger Wilco
talked about game demos and sort of
saying suggesting that they should be a
requirement in order to sort of offer a
pre-order which kind of makes sense it's
like hey if you're gonna ask us to
pretty buy a game maybe give us a free
taste in it you know game demos used to
be like really really common these come
discs in magazines but old dad gamer
responded by saying it's very easy for
developers to sort of create a demo
that's like a perfect slice of the game
and show that to you and then you can
still get third buy the rest of it we
also had a comment from Hendricks Milan
on YouTube saying no non crowdfunded
developers shouldn't get your money
until you get what you paid for
adding pre-order bonuses are just
content taken out of the game I think
that's an interesting thing that we
didn't talk about last time and there is
definitely an element of that and it's
also related to the backlash against DLC
especially DLC that is announced before
the game comes yeah totally certainly
the sentiment that is content taken out
of the game it's actually one of the
reasons
not a huge fan of DLC but I think
pre-ordering bonuses tend to be silly
things more often than not like skins or
extra items I'm personally not a huge
fan of that stuff particularly when they
give it to you before you start the game
and you just have this really powerful
like Opie item before you've even
started I don't even find that that
stuff becomes your obsolete like really
quickly and I find myself getting bang
you know those cities silly aesthetic
things just like things we use to
justify our silly decisions yeah but
that's just what we think so let us know
what you think and we'll be back next
week with another PC gaming topic
[Music]
you